please explain to us what FTX was so
we're still learning everything right so
everything is based on what we know
right now but Sam used to work at Jane
Street uh trading from Wall Street
subscribes to this idea of effective
altruism and basically like make as much
money as you can to do as much good in
the world as you can
everyone's a liar
everyone's a liar all right so that's
what he said yeah 32 billion was the
valuation of the company itself which
people were giving real money they
invested billions of dollars but the 32
number was just evaluation of the
company people were giving them money on
the exchange to buy and sell uh crypto
in their terms of service it said we
don't touch the coins that you give us
if you put your dollars in the bank what
do they do they lend it on the back
there are crypto companies that do the
same thing but FTX said we don't do that
it came out allegedly was like oh why
don't we take the user funds and like
bring it over here to the hedge fund
which is Alameda correct what I think is
clear is that like eight billion dollars
wasn't where it was supposed to be I
think it's maybe the best way to say it
right